[Music]
from the company who can milk a cash cow
almost as well as Disney comes the
internet sensation that has people all
over the world staring at their computer
screen saying geez you can get paid for
this nostalgia critic behold a comedian
with the squeegee high-pitched voice
like Sam Kinison only you wish this one
died instead of him getting recognition
for doing what no other person online
has ever done and like scream loudly get
facts wrong force painful means and act
like his opinion is the only one that
matters seriously do you guys even read
YouTube comments watch this entitled
nitpicking cry-baby give birth to a
million other entitled nitpicking cry
babies each one more desperate to ride
his coattails to internet fame and glory
kinda like what he did originally ah
question how this whiny little tool
actually got so much attention that
Hollywood constantly tries to take him
down for critiquing their worst
piece-of-shit material yeah taking down
a review of Cat in the Hat isn't gonna
change anyone's opinion on it guys
and doer a man with so little talent
that you'll be asking yourself how he
keeps getting celebrities you didn't
know you wanted to meet boys shit is
that Rufio
he looks amazing oh look it's pinging
the brain swearing at each other how the
hell did he get this well come on sit
back and enjoy an overly unqualified
twit rip apart terrible movies and shows
even though he's made terrible movies
and shows witness and clarify when an
obviously bad film is obviously bad
debate the ongoing question raised with
every episode what really counts as
nostalgic
I mean Jurassic world really and still
in theaters dude and see a man do what
you know you should be getting paid to
do but he just got to it a little bit
faster than you did
nanny nanny nanny starring the black eye
the shore chick
Rachel babes blasphemy that guy who's
probably funnier than everybody in the
Eve's way too many favors and white
privilege the job
if you're gonna download this you better
make it quick
because you never know what fuck you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember explosion okay that's a thing
[Music]
all right hold it right there
Jer what
[Music]
Oh buddy what parallel universe is this
what I've been in hypersleep for the
last 15 years and I wake up to this
upside-down topsy-turvy world are you
talking about I went online to research
the media of the last 15 years and I saw
Robocop poltergeist Willy Wonka and the
day the Earth Stood Still yeah those are
reboots what reboots like a remake kind
X I'm calling you to reap it gives an
excuse to suck why would you want to
remake something that's already perfect
it's like remaking Planet of the Apes oh
that one was so good Weaver made it
twice twice yeah you think Tim Burton
for that one Tim Burton that
groundbreaking visionary of original
content you're gonna want it down we mix
up in commonplace for years but people
forget when it was up an iconic film
that everybody loved it was not only
seen as bad taste to do a remake of it
but also not profitable however that was
all changed when Tim Burton's start
coining the phrase reimagining suddenly
the film wasn't seen this trying to make
something good even better but rather
show a different interpretation from a
likable artist this is what made us all
fall for something is obviously stupid
as the reimagining of Planet of the Apes
I know what you're thinking seriously
you guys couldn't tell back then that
this was going to be really really
really fucking bad you would there man
you weren't there for the incredible
advertising that trick the dumb out of
us everywhere the stars and the director
went they all said the same thing it's
not a remake it's a reimagining
reimagining I just want to do an action
film and play the ape see like a cool
environment to do it in and judging by
the trailer it kind of looks like it
would work okay this wasn't
thought-provoking commentary but but it
was a war a war to take back the planet
from those damn dirty Apes and tell you
the truth it kinda looked awesome
it's led to a big box office opening and
an even bigger response of people saying
son of a bitch they got us again when
will we wake up well no time soon as
even today shitty reboots are just as
popular as ever
what's it really worth it well let's
find out what Tim Burton's reimagining
on em you just like left in the middle
of the conversation I shot your leg like
four times but that's why I'm smoking
hey Malcolm yep Oh show Kimmy Schmidt
you're around and convince her this
isn't a parallel universe
I'm contam her to where the hell is she
oh yeah well I'm sure you can improvise
boy this means I get to introduce you
the key and peele for the first time I
really only like comedy about football
players names this is Tim Burton's
Planet of the Apes the film opens up
with boy I thought the effects would be
a little better than this actually it's
a test pilot monkey trained by Mark
Wahlberg who spends most of his time
with the space chimps and listening to
painful character exposition about
himself Frank I told you I would marry
you when I get back home it's legal now
but they come across the most dangerous
thing in any sci-fi movie space stuff
yeah you know space stuff nobody knows
what it is but I'll let you say some
technobabble with the words
electromagnetic thrown in it suddenly
can do anything tech initial radiation
gamma-ray readings an electromagnetic
storm bingo now a city of apes can
happen but when a monkey gets sucked in
and they're about to abort walberg grabs
his own space sperm endangering
everybody on board to rescue him so just
keep in mind everything that's about to
happen in this movie all happened
because of Wahlberg's monkey love
that'll have two more meanings as the
film goes on but we'll get to that the
blah blah electromagnetic blah blah blah
NOx Wahlberg on his ass causing him to
crash onto an unknown planet
Oh Artu how are we gonna get out of this
mess
but of course he comes across a horrible
discovery monkey
Oh
he's attacked by Cirque du so we've just
in time to witness the first of so many
bad in jokes I know I know
we're refunding your money now so the
first thing you might notice is that the
makeup in this movie is very pretty
spectacular I mean this film is over 14
years old and they look even more
convincing than the newer Planet of the
Apes movies it's actually one of the few
things that the remake did better than
the original the one downside though is
that the makeup clearly must have cost a
lot of money as they clearly didn't have
enough to pay the actors to come back
and read up their lines
it sounds like they say everything with
a mouth full of gorillas don't say what
up with your nonsense you like to
freshen up they're not dumb Jesus these
people get speaking lessons for biggest
tickets a senator's daughter flirts with
blasphemy let me come with you pussy I
may be a service it's a Wilk with youth
it also doesn't help that they forgot to
put Paul Giamatti and his eight make up
outwit let the mop into which group of
metaphors we want to assign each of them
metaphor metaphor you your metaphor yeah
it's kind of hard to figure out how even
the commentary is supposed to work in
the original it's just switched around
apes are smart and humans are dumb it's
easy to comprehend but in this one
sometimes they speak sometimes they
don't sometimes apes are shocked by
their intelligence but other times it
seems commonplace sometimes they're pets
but other times they're servants with
other Apes they're trying to throw in so
much obvious commentary that it's not
making any sense in the realm of its own
world I mean once the last time you saw
a movie about slavery where the slave
owner was like oh yeah so go and make
dinner after I figure out whether or not
you can speak English and that maybe
will prefetch for about a half hour so
wahlberg along with the other humans are
put in cages captured by the apes how
many times do I have to tell you wear
gloves when you handle humans especially
when they're touching Kris Kristofferson
but
they're worth more intact keep your eye
on this one
it's feisty yes he looked at you with
pure fear and put up no fight in being
captured the definition of feisty change
in this world this leads to our most
darling character in the entire film
fade played by Tim Roth I apologize for
my lateness senator they'll be their
chests and asked for my help
your family above all of being
compassionate we are not just soldiers
we're friends oh how do I describe him
imagine Chris Lambert and Clint Eastwood
fucked a monkey and that monkey got a
kidney stone while also being
constipated at the same time gives me
absolute wait wait I'm not finished then
somebody took sandpaper rubbed it all
over his face balls and vocal cords and
the only way he can feel better is by
constantly trying to bite his upper lip
let the Outpost do while doing a Kirk
Douglas impression upside down covered
in pubic hair
Tim Ron there are no words to describe
how amazingly over-the-top he is he's a
human hating general who's really given
no reason for his prejudice but by god
it makes up like 80% of his dialogue you
can free humans the human problem could
not be solved the human rights faction
of the humans was a fraud
the humans infest provinces the human
culture takes place below the waist well
if you hate him so much why don't you
marry him huh even it seems where you
have no idea what's going on he's a riot
like look at this scene where he
promises to get his knees a pet what the
hell just happened there is he so
intimidating that he's buttfucking his
mind is he tickling behind his ear which
happens to be Giamatti g-spot I still to
this day have no clue what's going on
thankfully this distracted from the rest
of the weird that was going on
thank you Tim Roth you phased out one
uncomfortable invasion of personal space
with another uncomfortable invasion of
personal space you'll find he's quite
good at that but an ape named Ari
played by future Tim Burton trope
the bottom Carter breaks in to fight for
Human Rights discount stand by while
human beings are being mistreated
tortured mutilated hey if you want me to
stop
give up your filthy business why does
her acting sound like William Shatner if
it was dug by a martial arts movie they
can be taught is our cities encroach
upon the habitat when the army burns the
bodies before they're examined Spock
don't make me kung fu this garment sell
them to me while their votes wild then
I'll buy them back the sorry lives out
every woman's dream of buying Mark
Wahlberg as we partake in this movie's
favorite pastime
awkward line holding what do I mean by
that well in most movies they'll usually
leave a pause after a really good line
because hey it's a really good line you
should let it sink in but here they just
kind of hold after any random line and
wash your hands before dinner do you
have a towel
in the time before time we should move
quickly these are not good minds holding
on them only makes us focus on how
poorly Winton they are but are you
posing for the laugh track that's
supposed to go over them Jojo so
Wahlberg picks his way out of the
easiest person to break out of ever well
he'll think the other humans break out
of the even easier prisons to break out
of ever gee it's a shame these things
haven't created steel oh fucking wait
they didn't somehow find the house
that's holding the kid that was sold as
a pet wow you look so sexy Lisa Jesus oh
my god it's those things we were totally
okay serving us just a moment ago Ari
also finds herself getting wrapped up in
the escape why did you help me what is
so unusual about him why is everybody
like watch him he's feisty oh you're so
unusual you're so unique I mean we know
he's different because we're the
audience but to everyone else he does
nothing different help if anything he
does less than everybody else so why
does he get all this attention yes what
this one seems different you have this
main character feel that we want
emphasized is interesting because we
forgot to write to you interesting no
special a is just he gets at the city
walls
but faith eventually finds out about
their escape she's helping them I saw
her myself
pony you stop touching me there please a
friend in life you're like 20 sexual
harassment suits waiting to have the
message to the Senate myself well that's
about the most obviously labeled secret
passage imaginable what you just hope
Bruce Wayne to hang up this sign
Giamatti and his goons follow them but
whoppers gives them away with his
weapons I'm probably just in the way
right now
so I just get going he'll lead them to
us unlikely to we clearly saw it scape
not two seconds ago hey we're looking to
embarrass a credible good actor no I
think that's the whole purpose of this
movie's existence what is that messenger
talks so sorry
that's not sorcery it's science daya
science something foreign to this world
that yet somehow has an understanding of
what planets are gives me absolute power
to rid this planet of the humans once
and for all just don't use steel in our
prison bars what kind of random with our
science but fate is told that his father
played by Charlton Heston is literally
on his death bed I don't have much time
my career will be dead soon
breakage
yeah I just kind of figured Heston
always had a gun hidden somewhere this
is the power of a thousand Spears I
warned y'all their ingenuity goes hand
in hand with their cruelty Wow
as an NRA spokesman I think the speech
is literally killing it wolf stuffing
father Dan
really movie you couldn't even do a
serious death scene without a little TV
haha in there first of all you did this
kind of joke already and over the
mountains of laughter that your denial
created it didn't go over very well
second you ruin what's supposed to be a
sad moment with a dumb joke I mean are
you supposed to feel bad or snicker at
this scene I don't think the invisible
laugh track we were talking about
earlier would react very well here
I think the writer needs more Prozac
[Applause]
you
[Music]
in a time of uncertainty only one
candidate has all the answers I want a
politician I know I can trust somebody
who speaks the truth and tells it like
it is
somebody I know who won't lie and
manipulate me for their own game you're
honest presidential candidate is here
with general Thade
most people say I look like a truffle
where they die someone I can get a beer
with appear me out the blood of stinking
humans I mean Huck's not in the
tradition of other obviously not bad
guys like Zachary Hale Comstock Senator
Palpatine and Skeletor comes a
politician who knows how to benefit all
mankind if clear the Republic rats are
trying to take away your freedoms your
freedoms disome it to me well it's like
my father used to say what he said
before he ate my children knows how to
keep communication open listening to all
the concerns of every voter he
encounters most people say that I'm
socially awkward because I invade that
personal space but just not good friends
like my pal Jesse yeah I know we are
friends because I'd probably clarify the
real friends we are friends right
yes we're beyond friends he doesn't mind
giving up his humanity for lack of
obedience what I did has the answers you
all have questions too I like someone
rugged and wild
but a good leader is only as good as his
second-in-command and I need somebody
who clearly understands human beings
that's why I've chosen a valuable vice
president that's right stupid humans you
can completely trust that I am this
literal man animal have your best
interests in mind whether its domination
or gold or whatever else there is you
can rest assure that we will always be
that point because if it's a radical
Overlord is going to rule you anyway it
might as well be from the party you
don't know but they did turn because
honestly what kind of surprise we got
this Bob stop touching me there no I
insist job they didn't Errol paid for by
the kinetic need of enforcing effective
laws
[Applause]
so they come across the forbidden area
that's supposed to keep humans out with
scarecrows as you can see and they're
clearly doing a bang-up job this world
makes no sense
anyway they come across a camp where the
Apes are waiting so they try to cross
the lake just grab the reins of one end
you hold on to this one as tight as you
can with the other oh great horseback
riding lesson there mark that's right up
there with the surf ninjas method of
teaching surfing
bend your knees move your arms nothing
but the Apes finest here they make it
across leaving at are played by Michael
Clarke Duncan to relay the bad news okay
five horses Oh what is happening right
this isn't ape acting folks I think
timber all just realizes roll in four
rooms is no longer even those
embarrassing work forgive me my friend
I'm not angry with you is that what that
was anger I thought you had lice in your
crotch or something
[Music]
computer-generated mouths
so Wow all the monkeys March the humans
clear him up I'd like to see a world
project pokken throw in a cage to it
protect me you know this scenario was
strange enough already I don't think
this edition of spanking the monkey is
absolutely essential No and look you
make googly face sad seriously
what we actually has that even supposed
to be
so they find mark Whalberg ship known to
the Apes as the secret holy land of Kali
ma
try the human hearts I hear that
delicious but it appears to be a little
dated these ruins are thousands of years
old I was here a few days ago of course
like most religions this one started
because the founders didn't know how to
brush dust away ship has nuclear power
so he's supposed to last forever oh good
and the wires are nuclear to the knobs
all the connecting lines lasted
thousands and thousands of years
beautiful you should open a Wahlburgers
is here but word spreads through the
villages pretty fucking fast when you
think about it as many more people want
to join Walberg stories spreading
through the villages they all want to
see this human who defies the Apes yes
and as we clearly seen before nobody has
ever stood up to the Apes but he just
did it in such a disinterested way we
can see re meets up with they to try and
trade herself for the human survival
you know fade there's only so many
Facebook profile pictures I can switch
out of you and you're hilarious faces my
anger picture from inside out with like
a turn buddy gives are a pretty definite
no and returns are back to the humans
this leads to our big battle the next
morning and I know you can I need you
back there with them okay Oh fuckin gee
I wonder what's going to happen let me
go with him no let me prove I can help
no really you needed to repeat that you
really think we missed the incredibly
subtle foreshadowing of what's about to
occur
why dumbass kid what are you doing here
I'm 40 yes that no I'm staying I signed
up to be the idiot pawn in this thinker
and I'm gonna live out to my uselessness
oh my god he fell I mean what what I
really thought he was gonna be an
important and useful character I'm sure
glad they didn't make him the
scrappy-doo of shit-eating tools of
course Wahlberg goes to save and that
gets back to the ship using the last of
the nuclear power to blow em sky-high
all right kids start ripping some hands
off and make some wishes they apparently
survived that their armor must be made
of a million point million sunblock but
they decides he's tired of the stupid
I'm tired of it too much I summon the
battle cry of my testicles big Titans
they Pro taken a fight with more strings
being pulled in government they even
tries to kill wahlberg via facial but
suddenly a ship is seen falling from the
sky and now we all know the origins of
Lancelot link but even though he seems
to get along with Wahlberg and the Apes
mistake him for the Savior they still
just let him fall under attack and
apparently not do anything
have fun fade will just stay out here
and pick ticks out of our asses play
nice with God we saw Messiah unless you
know how to kill my whole character in
an Avengers movie are not interested but
at least one person comes in -
apparently discover the truth this is
where you're from
we brought you it's the truth
we've can piece together well outside of
exploiting it even killing you for a
space programs but outside of that a
very imprisoned piece he's lying help me
my friend come on don't make me act more
like a CAD bass villain that I already
am everything I have believed is a lie
you and your family have retreated us is
human I was going to kill a second ago I
now completely abandon my religion for
long live the Flying Spaghetti Monster
fade is imprisoned as will Burke finds
the location of the storm and hopes to
get home through it after just a little
bit more awkwardness you know one day
they'll tell a story
[Music]
that's pretty fucking gross you couldn't
quite sell us on the bestiality thing
there Burton that was pretty
uncomfortable to be fair though I do
believe the kiss between the monkey and
the human more than I believe the kiss
between the human and the human whoa
wait do we have a thing that one
completely or Maya I guess I love you or
whatever bye well I'm sorry
I dig monkeys now if you'll excuse me if
there's an orangutan with lipstick on
her ass that's waiting for me to come
home he goes through the storm and crash
lands back home no I'm all right really
it loosened up my muscles when we get a
twist just as massive just as shattering
and just as disturbing as the original
Planet of the Apes
movie movie hello Bobby
movie movie yes you not only do we have
no idea how fate could have done this as
there's no other ships but the timeline
suggests you can't really alter the
present just help it become what it
already is but even taking that out of
the equation what are the chances that
they taking over the earth result in the
exact same outcome as our society
location as everything else is in our
world and the police uniforms and the
cars and the buildings what's this part
of things plan like before she died
years and years ago he was telling some
architects you know I have some plaques
just some architectural designs that
maybe you could put in place in the
future cursor I kind of came from the
world ruled by humans it's a long story
but I saw this world and they were good
designs they were just really good
design strong stuff and that if you
could just duplicate that as best as
possible to try to get it down guys like
really to the letter because if one of
us humans from that society was to
crash-land here at the I could oh my god
I'm home and they see like my face on
the Lincoln Memorial you don't know who
Lincoln is he's a guy but he would see
it it just yeah I got my god oh you damn
dirty hate that this mine will be blown
so if you could just really get that as
close as humanly possible I'd be very
appreciative so uh good luck with that
and um fade-out so yeah all of humanity
has been taken over by monkeys the human
race is practically extinct all because
of Y again monkey love so if there's
anything that this film is clearly
trying to get across don't do it that's
the only thing I got out of this film
it looks nice I mean the makeup is
amazing and the attention to detail on
how they move and so forth it's really
something to admire
but even as dumb action movies go I mean
really just barebone cool stuff it's
still just awkward
everyone acts a little too weird to be
invested and the main characters are
sticks in the mud so you don't really
care if they win or not sometimes you
get a good character actor giving a good
performance but even they can't fight
against faulty sci-fi and forced
commentary that we already know is gonna
be done well better in the original
thankfully we see some other good films
from Burton because this one was
definitely a Bad Monkey to see through
and like I said this isn't the first
film to start the big reboot craze but
is the first one to show it could be
popular make a lot of money and also
show very clearly that idiots like us
will be duped into anything okay I've
come to terms with the fact that this
world has completely run out of original
ideas the faster you learn that the
better but that also means that I can
see one of my favorite childhood
cartoons up on the big screen again and
all of its glory
I wouldn't go looking for that you might
not like what you find
thanks for key and Peele hey everyone
should see the substitute teacher Critic
what will she find her destiny
No
finally really
oh my god I cannot wait to see this
movie
right
[Music]
[Applause]
you
do you have a towel